peter was ist denn der wellenbrecher
lockt ja ganz simpel gesagt der lockdown
der die zweite welle brechen soll also
die welle droht zu hoch zu gehen
exponentielles wachstum wir haben es
gehört peter altmaier rechnet mit über
20.000 ende des ende des monats was auch
daran liegt dass sich die kanzlerin
damals bei ihrer rechnung mit den 19.200
grob verrechnet hat um den faktor 25
sie hat schlicht zu niedrig gerechnet es
kommt jetzt alles früher es kommt alles
also schneller und das muss die welle
gebrochen werden
das ist ein konzept das stammt von
christian drosten von dem virologen von
der charité und von karl lauterbach den
gesundheitsexperten der spd die haben
das mal entworfen schon vor mehreren
wochen
jetzt wird es gebraucht aus der
schublade geholt und darauf wie sich die
kanzlerin morgen mit den
ministerpräsidenten einigen bars clubs
restaurants zu kontakt beschränkungen
für zwei wochen ganz hart weil wie
carlotta was sagt das ist die letzte
patrone wenn wir auf unserem sonderweg
bleiben wollen sonst gut geht es uns wie
die in spanien und den holländern und
kone hat auch auswirkungen auf die wahl
des neuen cdu parteivorsitzenden der der
parteitag ist verschoben was dich um
gehört hast stimmen eingesammelt heute
im bundestag wir haben rein
wir können natürlich der cdu es keine
ratschläge erteilen aber insgesamt
glaube ich werden wir alle dankbar wenn
auch eine wahlauseinandersetzung so
gehandhabt wird
dass wir nachher gestärkt daraus
hervorgehen und nicht gespalten und und
im laden machen noch was übrig bleibt
also ich würde sagen es war zunächst die
richtige entscheidung den präsenz
parteitag abzusagen
es gibt aber natürlich jetzt den bedarf
dass klarheit darüber herrscht wann denn
die digitale parteitag stattfindet und
ich kann schon verstehen dass viele
mitglieder sich jetzt wünschen dass die
führungsfrage eben auch entschieden wird
und nicht auf unbestimmte zeit vertagt
und deswegen wünsche ich mir den
digitalen partei dagegen falls lieber
früher als später die grundlage ist
jetzt erstmal das man unter angesicht
der situation das heißt der pandemischen
lage eine entscheidung getroffen hatte
ein parteitag zu verschieben das kann
ich gut verstehen dass es
nachvollziehbar damit muss man umgehen
das entspricht nicht der erwartung die
der ein oder andere hatte von da ist
auch klar dass es enttäuschungen
gibt aber es läuft nicht alles nach plan
wenn man sich um höchste ämter bewirbt
das ist ganz normale situation
ja ich glaube gerade wenn man sich für
höchste ämter bewirbt dann ist es doch
die kunst das unerwartete zu beherrschen
die verschiebung war jetzt sehr
unglücklich denn es hätte möglichkeiten
gegeben und hätte auch formate gegeben
dass wir jetzt am 5 dezember diese
entscheidung herbeiführen
und ich bin auch der festung erzeugen
sollten schnellstmöglich diese
entscheidung herbeiführen werden der
früheste termin jetzt eben der
sechzehnte januar ist dann sollte man
diese auch nehmen notfalls als online
parteitag mit anschließend schriftlicher
abstimmung aber die entscheidung darf
sich ein halbes jahr aus gezögert werden
aber jetzt geht es auch darum die eigene
meinung zurück stellen zu können ich war
auch für den dezember als parteitag wenn
auch und auch möglicherweise digital
jetzt ist dabei eine linie gefunden
worden
wir können jetzt im januar einen
digitalen parteitag machen und jetzt
finde ich das wichtigste das wir einig
sind und verlässlich einen plan finden
dass wir ganz zu beginn des jahres auch
einen vorsitzenden wählen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren